obviously you have hit a nerve because
of what's unfolded during the covid
years and you know it was something that
I was disturbed by a lot of coveted
policy including the implementation and
mandating of the vaccines although not
necessarily their creation
I also think vaccines on net save a lot
of lives whether we are talking about
the coveted vaccine or something like
measles which I'm just going to pull
this slide up real quick this is showing
the measles vaccine being licensed in
1963 all these sources will be in our
description and on our web page but then
you see after the licensure the measles
cases drastically decline it was
basically eliminated by in the U.S by
the year 2000 and then started coming
back as people got complacent stopped
vaccinating so much uh and then by 2
2019 there were up to a thousand over a
thousand cases and these outbreaks
occurred in places where
unsurprisingly under vaccinated
communities communities that objected to
the vaccines for religious reasons and
so forth or political reasons so that is
that is my concern it's that
um I you know I think some of your
critiques of what happened during the
coveted years are totally legitimate but
I worry that your rise in elevation is
going to possibly accelerate the return
of more diseases that heretofore have
been eradicated what do you say to an
independent voter like me who's in that
mindset um and who is voted for
Republicans were voted for Democrats
voted for Libertarians before but has
this you know concern hanging over my
head
I never have been if you show me a
vaccine that works and that makes people
healthier
the MMR vaccines don't work well I would
like to see data that show that people
I would like to see if vaccinated versus
unvaccinated study that showed that
people
who get the MMR vaccine are in uh are
healthier uh a decade later how do you
explain this graph you know you said
many things that are you know a part of
the kind of industry propaganda
one is that a vaccine that you know
those later rises
in vaccination in uh in measles come
from unvaccinated Individual come from
the you know the complacency but vaccine
vaccination rates have gone up
continuously there's no time in our
country
of vaccination rates have dwindled have
gone lower so they they continue to go
so there's not a time when they went
lower that those that suddenly you see
about you can look at isolated
communities for a variety of reasons
it is it is slipping down this is an
article showing that you know
kindergarten vaccination rates have been
dropping especially uh it's starting
2019 but post covet it's still very high
it's in the high 90s but it's gone from
like 95 to 93 percent and what I think
the science shows about vaccines is that
these numbers you know we don't really
know what the threshold is but once you
start getting below 90 and 85 then
that's when you know as a parent of
young children I start to get you know
pretty nervous uh that we're going to
have outbreaks can I answer you yes
okay number one
you have to check in those outbreaks to
see whether the fact whether the the uh
the kids who are getting the measles are
actually unvaccinated and what strain it
is for example in the Disneyland strain
we know that it leaves 36 percent
of the kids who got measles were vaccine
strained measles what we're seeing is
the vaccine waves and after 20 years
there's extreme lightning
oh the vaccine has not been around that
long and when the the the the the
uh generation that got that that got
measles like myself dies off
you're going to see a lot of me return
to measles now I'm
measles mortality used to be tremendous
to our country oh it used to heal tens
of thousands of children a year
prior to 1964 prior to the introduction
the vaccine that mortality dropped off I
think the year the vaccine it was down
to about two or three hundred people a
year almost all those children were
Mountaineers the deaths from measles
so the death from these were declining
anyway and there's a study that the CDC
did in 2000 called and it's I and it was
published in I think uh Pediatrics and
they did it with Johns Hopkins
and they asked the question did vaccines
contribute to this dramatic decrease in
mortalities among American children that
have an aft in the 20th century
and after looking at all the data they
came back and said no the vaccine said
almost nothing to do with it what what
what was responsible for those declined
mortalities was engineering Solutions it
was better Nutrition a coordinated water
hygiene good food Etc and lower density
housing
so
um now then there's the other question
is it beneficial to get measles on your
kid is that beneficial I uh I speak as a
survivor of measles moms and chickenpox
diseases that no longer exist and me too
so you know for example
in Europe they don't allow the
chickenpox vaccine we make it here and
why don't they allow it because if you
give kids a chicken pox vaccine you're
much more likely
to get on uh shingles when you're older
and we now have you have the vaccine
exactly wrong right it's like if you
have the chickenpox as a child you're
more likely to get shingles or the
vaccine
if you get if you if we have wild
chickenpox what the wild Chicken Box did
is every two years it would come back
and if you were if you got it when you
were a kid when it came back it was it
functioned as a booster so if you would
never get shingles
the people who used to get shingles were
people who were isolated from children
so they attended when I was young it
shingles was associated with old
curmudgeons who never went near kids
if you were near kids and you got that
exposure you wouldn't get shingles so
now that we've eliminated that annual
annual booster that people got I mean
shingles epidemic and you know the CDC
did a study in fact a scientist they did
an extensive five or ten year study
in Antelope Valley California by a
scientists that they had an NIH Sciences
contract scientists called Gary Goldman
and he predicted he said if you do this
vaccine this Mass vaccination we are
going to have massive shingle epidemic
in 10 years and that's exactly what
happened and if you go on NHS website
today the National Health Service
in England it will say on that website
on the home page we do not
um mandate the chickenpox vaccine
because it causes shingles epidemics now
with measles
well there are lots and lots of studies
out there that so if you got measles as
a kid you're much you are you have a
heightened immunity
against certain kinds of cancers against
ectopic disease against cardiac disease
and Allergic Disease when you get older
so having those childhood diseases which
were essentially rashes in many cases
you um and we're you know self-limiting
and and harmless and to almost all
children
you it immunizes you and it builds your
immune response in the future against
all kinds of really bad diseases that
actually kill you
there's also uh you know uh real risks
of uh you know bad outcomes for all
these diseases whether they are measles
mumps and rubella and you know it is
hard to look at charts like the one I
put up before or this one that has to do
with polio that has a similar story 1955
I have marked here is where the vaccine
was licensed polio plummets we know
polio and even more severe disease that
uh I would hope none of us would want to
see come back and so I guess first I'll
just ask you you know are you worried
about something like polio and then
secondly what is what would be your
policy approach to these vaccines would
you actually
allow people to continue getting the
people who want the vaccines to still
get them or would you ban some of these
vaccines outright
oh I would yeah I'm not I wouldn't I
won't mandate vaccines if anybody wants
to get a vaccine you should get it
what I'll do is I'll make sure we have
good science that's all and then let
people make up their own minds and by
the way eighty percent of the polio
cases on Earth today according to the
who are vaccines trained polio that
means people got it from vaccinated
people can I uh just to drill down
because I think those cases are
extremely low uh as you can see by this
chart so if it's 80 it's 80 it's a very
small number worldwide polio is almost
eradicated so just you know
it is eradicated in the United States
but it's not eradicated around the world
and as I said the who is it is a killer
around the world
according to WHL 80 of it is vaccine
strain can I ask that you would make
sure the science is solid what would uh
like uh what would be your method for
doing that I I
um saw a recent report from Anna merlon
from the uh from Vice who uh watched
your recent Health policy Summit I
couldn't find the the recording to
review myself so this is her reporting
she said that you would be actually you
said you would be actually issuing
executive orders from the Oval Office to
kind of shape Health policy and also
kind of Target medical journals that you
felt had uh I don't know been captured
is that an accurate characterization to
your what Your approach would be uh to
health policy from the Oval Office yeah
my my Approach will be to appoint good
people
who will actually do safety signs
there's not one of the 72 vaccine doses
now mandated for American children that
have ever been through a
placebo-controlled study relicester
as outrageous every other medicine has
to go through pre-licensing safety
studies the vaccines are the only ones
that are exempt
and we're mandating them for healthy
children and all I'm saying is
let's do a real safety study so that we
know the risk profile on these products
we know what the benefits are and then
give people the real you know the real
information and we can't do that today
because we do not have
the same thing why are we giving
rotavirus vaccines how many lives do
those say and I ask can I ask with if
you know in a RFK FDA uh drugs now
currently you know cost a billion to two
billion dollars to bring to Market a
decade or more would drug approval be
easier or harder and what has been the
role of pharmaceuticals in increasing
health and lifespan over the past 50
years
of pharmaceutical drugs I mean again the
only thing the only studies that we have
on that are the McKinley and McKinley's
in 77 and the two well what what an FDA
would would your FDA
let me answer that question
uh Peter Gosha who's the founder of the
Cochran collaboration which is the most
prestigious group of independent
scientists 30 000 scientists who review
clinical data for the pharmaceutical
industry
um has done it recently issued a report
that show that uh pharmaceutical drugs
are now the third biggest killer in
America after
um after heart attacks and cancer
so no I do not intend to make it easier
to get drugs to Market I I think that
drugs should have drugs that are
on that have a uh have a some special uh
with their you know situation when
there's people dying that they should be
made available to them
but no I don't I what I think we should
be doing is looking at public health and
we should be looking at all forms of of
helping public health and boosting
people's immune systems not just
pharmaceutical products and not just
pharmaceutical Solutions we we now have
because of the way that things are done
in this country
because of the corruption of these
agencies we now have the sickest
population on Earth we have the highest
chronic disease rate of any country
why is it that we had 16 of the coveted
deaths in this country we only have four
percent of the world population it's
because our people are so sick and we've
done such a miserable job
at building Public Health you know we
pay more for medicine than any country
in the world we use more of it and
Americans with the sick as we're 79th in
the world in terms of health outcome
we're behind Mongolia behind Cuba we are
not doing it right we need intervention
and we need people to come in with a new
way of doing things in those agencies
and to be to be clear just to follow to
get an answer to that earlier question
you would be using your executive power
executive orders to accomplish that goal
to make it harder for certain drugs to
make it to Market or certain vaccines I
didn't say that but I said I want good
science
that show that these drugs actually work
and not the kind of corrupt trials that
we've had today okay well you did say
that it would be harder to bring drugs
to Market yeah
you know in some cases it may be harder
to bring up the market I don't think let
me let me go back and say I don't intend
to make it more difficult for you to
bring them to Market I think
um some of them I I do think that we
need to look at the fast track approval
process because it doesn't make any
sense to me that 50 almost 50 percent of
fda's budget is now coming from the
pharmaceutical industry do you think
that the covid vaccine which we're an
agreement should not have been mandated
across Society for all ages regardless
of circumstance but do you believe that
on net it saved lives that it prevented
people from dying of covid I think that
I mean according to its own you know the
Pfizer clinical trial data
the vaccine saves one life for every 22
000 vaccines administered from covet one
life
and it paid and it takes four lives from
cardiac arrest so and then you know so
that's one data point we I have a whole
book of data points that I've called I
called died suddenly
it shows all of them the massive data
points that indicate that the vaccine
actually uh cause more problems than it
affirmative so and I'll just give you
this one data point to listen to to
think about
and this isn't just positive but there's
many of them there are many that I think
are
we are one of the most vaccinated
coveted vaccinated countries in the
world and we had the highest death rate
in the world from covet
um
Haiti which had a one percent 1.4
vaccination rate had a death rate one
200th of our country
Nigeria which had a 1.3 vaccination rate
at a death rate 1 200th of our country
on all if you look at the and look at
Nation by nation and go through the
Johns Hopkins data
which is all graphed in the first page
or oh you'll show that the real deaths
came following vaccination the xss and
that's exactly what the Pfizer clinical
trial predicted happened yeah I will say
that you know comparing across countries
like this you have to take into account
things like demographics age health
status so it's really hard to do that
what we can say is you know I'll just
pull up this is the covid weekly death
rate by vaccination status all ages in
the U.S that orange line at the top
shows unvaccinated compared to
vaccinated and vaccinated with booster
and um I mean it's hard to dispute that
a lot of people who would have otherwise
died from covid looking at that probably
lived because of the vaccine so again
you've got your book you've got your
footnotes we've got uh some slides we
pulled up today we've got uh notes to
sources and people can you know sort
these things out but I just you know
want to make the case that uh it's
possible to be critical of the way that
the government uh approached this and
kind of the heavy-handedness with which
some of the the covid vaccines were
mandated while accepting that um there
were some serious benefits as well and
and that's where where I stand with this
at the end of the day I'm happy to show
you graphs that show the opposite and
I'm happy to show you the public data
and that you know is generally
acknowledged now
that there was not a greater death rate
among the vaccinated than the uh the
greater death rate the higher death
rates were among the vaccinated and I'll
tell you one of the problem that graph
Perceptions in that graph is the way
they calculated
vaccinated because the way they
calculated it for that graph
is that they you were unvaccinated until
two weeks after
your second vaccine right because that's
when it has full protection kicked in
according to the CDC that's right but
but the big death rate if you look at
all the Johns Hopkins data the big death
rate from the vaccine and you know
because people were getting covered
right after getting vaccinated
and the big Death Race then were
happening immediately after the first
vaccine so those death rates were
counted among unvaccinated people even
though they were fully they were
vaccinated
and you're that's what your graph your
graph is picking up that artifact I was
actually picking up
that the vaccines cause excess deaths
well the vaccines
you know don't trust me go and look at
the graphs the Johns Hopkins grass died
suddenly and you will see that yes that
is true can I ask just as a general
closing thought and I'm going to give
you the last uh word here in in a RFK
America would you know that which is not
mandatory is outlawed I mean like this
part of part of what we're struggling
with when we you know when we pull back
a little bit is that we seem to live in
a world now where either something is
mandatory or it is outlawed um and I
think a general libertarian perspective
is that what we want to do is give more
individuals more breathing room to
choose how to live to you know have more
autonomy in how they go about their
daily business and you know you know
what is your pitch to deliver that kind
of world I guess well I mean I think
that's what I've been saying throughout
I don't know my inclination
is not demanding things but give people
a choice you know if if somebody wants
to get vaccinated
I have no problem with that I just don't
think you should mandate it and
particularly for a product that has you
know that that has no insurance policy
and that carries over into a wide array
of policy areas and things like that I
believe in Freedom of Choice
unless it's going to hurt your neighbor
or you know it's going to hurt the
comments you know people should be able
to do what they want with as much
Freedom as possible and the government
should not be on any hey thanks for
watching that excerpt from our
conversation with Robert F Kennedy Jr
about his Run for the Democratic
presidential nomination you can watch
the full interview right here or another
excerpt from that right here